[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم مع دخول حرب غزه يومها
ال وزاره الصحه تقول ان الاحتلال ارتكب 12
مشجره في 24 ساعه والامم المتحده تصف
التصريحات الاسرائيليه بنقل العمليات
العسكريه الى رفح بالمقل والخطره وتجدون
المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق
الاول قصف امريكي لموا في العراق وسوريا
ما دفع بغداد لاستدعاء القائم بالاعمال
الامريكي في حين وصف الحشد الشعبي الضربه
بالانتهاك الصارخ لسياده العراق وقالت
الخارجيه السوريه ان العدوان يؤجد الصراع
في المنطقه كما وصفت طهران الهجوم بالخطا
الاستراتيجي قوات حفظ السلام الافريقيه في
الصومال تعلن استكمال المرحله الثانيه من
مغادرتها للبلاد وذلك بسحب 3000 جندي
وتسليم قوا واعد عسكريه للحكومه في مقديشو
هذه الخطوه تاتي بعد تعليق استمر ثلاثه
اشهر استجابه لطلب من الحكومه الصوماليه
اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص بجروح احدهم في حاله
خطره في حادثه طعن بمحطه ليون للقطارات
بباريس الشرطه الفرنسيه اعتقلت منفذ
الاعتداء وقالت انه يحمل رخصه قياده
ايطاليه ويعاني من اضطرابات نفسيه الى
اللقاء
ه